je vous présente une énorme télé
aujourd'hui c'est une télé de LG qnd 75
pouces c'est vrai qu'on est habitu à
avoir des 55 65 75 pouces c'est énorme
mais ça offre un très très bon confort
de visionnage cette techno qnd je sais
pas si vous connaissez c'est un mélange
de technologie quanton dot et nanoell on
va avoir des couleurs viv une télé très
lumineuse des noires intenses des super
contrastes et grâce à la technologie
mini LED énormément de détail et ce que
je trouve super avec ce téléviseur c'est
également son design déjà vous avez un
pied central ça c'est extrêmement
pratique vous pouvez la mettre quasiment
n'importe où elle est pour autant
extrêmement fine et puis bien évidemment
la performance n'est pas en res on va
retrouver le processeur alpha 7 ai4k gen
6 avec une techno d'apprentissage basée
sur li bre c'est vachement cool on a
bien évidemment Dolby visision Dolby
Atmos une super expérience de gaming en
4K 120 Hz avec le free 5 et en plus de
ça deux ports HDMI 2.0 et une expérience
logiciel dédiée on a également de l'allm
pour avoir une faible latence l ce que
vous allez venir jouer de l'IARC et puis
bien évidemment du cloud gaming avec
notamment jeforce Nao je vous invite à
découvrir ce téléviseur sur le site de
LG je vous en ai fait une vidéo longue
sur ma chaîne youtube on sait la voir
parce que c'est extrêmement intéressant